i just can't believe how much of a crazy
small world property investment is
so i worked with glenn glenn found a
deal
many of his deals went well one of his
deals didn't go well because of that
andrea put glenn in touch with lee lee
then was introduced to chris
the landlord lee then got lots of deals
from chris and he's making good money
i've now been introduced to lee from
andrea my student
lee's kindly showing me around his
houses and different things i'm learning
loads
it's just such a small world i can't
believe
this so this is a lease option agreement
okay i can kill this dude right here hey
what's up my name is samuel leeds i'm
standing outside this beautiful detached
house in blackpool this isn't the
nice part of blackpool though right so
we've got like seven hundred thousand
pound houses around here we certainly
have and stanley park directly
stanley park directly opposite so this
house lee bought this house
on a lease option agreement is that
correct that's correct
so how much money did you need to put
down in total in terms of legal fees
refurb to secure this house four
thousand pounds
four thousand pounds you have the option
to buy it not the obligation
yeah for how much for 210
in how many years seven so in seven
years time lee has the option to buy
this property for two hundred and ten
thousand pounds
how much is it worth right now uh
between two
fourteen to eighteen two four right now
and is it making you cash flow each
month
it is how much uh it's it's it's taking
cash flow he's taking 3 300
pence uh to uh and it's making me
a thousand pounds 1200. so he's renting
this out for 3
300 making a clean profit of a thousand
to 1200 a month can we go and have a
look around
so let's do it i love this it's so it's
got such a good feel about it yeah it's
very homely
it is okay so is that everything at the
moment yeah i've got six nurses
right uh and what four nurses
two doctors oh you know you're winning
when you've got doctors
and nurses yes the two were very very
very
they're not they're not from the same
league at all right
uh you tend to find that to get them to
mix you now
you normally find it's an emergency team
yeah that are together that they can
work together so when you've got the
doctors yeah
emergency arm emergency doctor off and
you tend to find that the two swot
between themselves when they find a team
yeah yeah that works together to grow at
the hospital
it's really really hard
yeah and again we're just starting to
catch up on the rubbish so is this one
of the properties
um that you might have this is a bad
direct
a rental bag oh like a lease option
yes that's so cool good that's so cool
so you're a property investor
you do lease option rent to buyers yeah
i have a property management company
yeah all in blackboard development
company yeah and a development company
yeah
great oh man this is fabulous i can see
why you wanted to buy this place
long term long term so what's seven
seven years
agreement what's it worth now about
three twenty three
oh my goodness i need to talk to you
about how to get these deals in
blackball
absolutely fabulous your background is
interesting because you
you earned some harvester yeah so i was
a general manager harvester restaurants
for
uh mitchell butlers uh three on the foul
coast
um uh which which was
a vocation really uh and after quite a
messy divorce
uh i decided to uh the three properties
that i did have
i decided to liquidate those and put
everything into one property
yeah that then fell on through um
my father um they had
or the family business was kcs
a contact by the london office
um gave me a number to a guy that was
looking to invest
in property a gentleman from dubai
uh and i sold out to the arabs i bought
for 400
sold for 1.2 million very good
uh with the tenants in doing what i was
doing originally it was
going to be the family home uh and
obviously i didn't need a seven bedroom
mansion so uh what i decided to do was
to sell
and separate that asset and actually
turn it into a business
you've done it really well for yourself
yeah yeah yeah good really really well
for yourself and this property
is just amazing
wardrobe as well very nice and how much
does this rent out for then
this year this one rents out for five
five fifty
uh yeah per calendar month amazing that
you can get that kind of rent
in blackpool and is that that again it
is it is a professional
yeah in terms of the social then we do
change the bedding
and the bedding is laundered so there is
that slightly higher
yeah you've gone for the boutique kind
of luxury yes
and to be fair with the nurses what they
want after a 14 18 hour day sometimes
is to come back to a clean bed uh a
house that's warm
a house that's clean and yeah but that
makes
it painful it makes sense what you've
done
so well he's brought the hospitality
industry
into the property industry yeah yeah
exactly
that's how you've differentiated
yourself yeah that's your usp
yeah yeah because when there's when
there's a i mean when there's a lot of
supply and a lot of demand it's about
saying okay well how can my supply be
different because there is a lot of
demand in blackpool
there is a lot of you got to be very
unique in what you do
and if you want the taurus you can get
that if you want that
it's uh blackpool is very dynamic uh
and obviously through coverage what
we've done with the as
is turn those into um terminals into
short-term lats
yeah and then turn them back into um
as covert is released so uh the deals
and things that we've got
uh aren't uh my i'm actually
i'm actually delivering on my contract
as well
so um things like uh services
accommodation
has gone to residential i think it's
done i know you're really smart but i'm
just gonna ask you a question about that
we're in blackpool yeah we really
struggled to find a hotel last night
yeah it was full you know that because
you had to help find us
hotels yeah yeah so
you say i'm turning all the essays back
to residential but does that
is why when there's when essays do so
wow
there was so much uncertainty um yes my
contract
uh my contracts that were in place all
the people that we do business with
was to be a man of my word deliver on
what we said people
so you thought when when corona was
happening lockdown was happening you
thought oh this is sketchy
switching days again really knew what
was going to
happen yeah how it was going to turn out
so we played the safe game
how did you find how did you find
richard because i mean he's a real rock
in the business
richard me and richard richard had
nightclubs
so we were aware of each other and aware
of each other's
uh i come from hospital where lee came
from
the daytime i came from the late night
yeah okay so and we know a lot of the
same people as well
what's the difference richard when you
talk a hat and what's the switch between
talking to an investor
who who owns the property potentially
who's a multi millionaire
and a tenant because i know you're not a
respecter of persons
everyone's equal but what's the trick
and what's the difference
but when you speak into the the owner of
the building
it's the way i do it is i although i'm
neutral and sat on the middle
i'm when i speak to either side i come
across as if i'm on
their side so yeah i've always got their
best interest so if it's a problem
tenant
i can i can level with them and say look
i can put why don't we try this why
don't we try
that and it's about conflict resolution
more than anything
and it's been on the side of both
parties
staying neutral at the same time
brilliant you know
which is the best for our clients yeah
you're like a mediator yeah this is an
issue because because a
multi-millionaire landlord
probably can't understand a tenant
who's paying 500 degrees they're in a
different world completely and the
tenant can't understand the landlord
they just think oh why can't you just
pay for this and pay for that and let me
have this for free sometimes yeah and
then
the landlord's like just getting my rent
and well shut up but
being that was not actually being that
that mediator yet i think that's why a
lot of
property investors the biggest problem
and this is why i'm so grateful for you
though the biggest problem that i see
amongst property investors is poor
management of the properties yeah that's
the biggest problem
you have a landlord who just thinks i
don't even need management or i'll just
pay for the cheapest
yeah and and they just see it purely but
actually if you've got a cheap
management company that's not doing a
good job and not putting their all into
it
you're going to have a you're going to
have absolute nightmare and from the
landlord's perspective because you
charge 15
yeah does that charge 50. is that
including the 80 or plus v8
that's possibly 80. okay so 15 plus v8a
which some investors would bulk at
they'd say that's too expensive
well that's fine you know at the end of
the day we deliver a good product
we get a result our tenants are
consistent yeah
um and we deliver we work
for the client at the end of the day
i wouldn't say it was too expensive i'm
just saying a lot
and a lot a lot of people that would say
it's expensive are people that have been
in the game six months
yeah you've been in the game six years
and you know the difference between
someone
like your company who's gonna who's
gonna you know find
good tenants vet them manage them
liaise media get the rent collect the
rent if the rents like chase the rent
send it on time do a nice statement not
rip the investor off and put in
i'm sure you have maintenance people
around yes maintenance people
doing that and doing that to a quality
with your heart in it
i'd pay 15 plus for the aj absolutely
and every day our clients
um like a good friend of mine uh andrea
we actually manage one of her properties
uh and she's completely hands off
her was to be financial freedom and what
she wanted to do
one of my students right yeah yeah yeah
yeah she is yeah
so what she wanted was the financial
freedom to spend more time with her
family
quality time with her family so that her
investments are working for her
so that's her personal um
dream or or focus or goal
uh and that's what we deliver for andrea
so she is completely hands off and
andreas
i think she's actually visited the
property three times since
had to purchase well andrea introduced
me to you and she and she and she
sang your praises so much and yeah and i
know you've done a lot of work
generally in the area but she was like
you need to meet this guy
he's really helped me out and she found
you
by following my system of which is buy
low rent high with a property manager
nearby yes that's my philosophy um and
she found you so
absolutely and it's that local it's that
local understanding
of the area by where you know right yeah
absolutely because the thing is you can
find blackpool
and blackpool's one of those sketchy
areas in my opinion where
if you don't know the area like for
instance normally the closer you are to
the center
the better so oh i'm really close look
the tower's there and then where whereas
in blackpool the closer you go to the
center
the worse the worse which is weird it is
it is
it is very bad but feel like
everything's like
what pool's a very unique place where
the top of the road can be completely
different to the bottom of the road yes
so you need to either know the area
yourself or you need to be able to
bounce property deals off
of people i came to blackpool
when i was 17 years old 12 years ago
came to blackpool didn't know the area
from adam came because i didn't have any
money and i wanted to do some no money
down deals some lease option agreements
i wanted to do some um by
by refinance same day this has been
mortgage express for a thing
and i came to blackpool i didn't know
anything and i was just going to estate
agents talking asking questions getting
to know the area
and this guy called michael stone
blonde hair took me in his fancy car
took me around for about three hours did
a little map show me all the streets and
everything
i've never met michael stone since but
even though i was just a kid
and i didn't have any money or anything
i'm still so grateful and i've not ever
been able to find
this guy since michael stone if you're
watching this buddy michael stone
i appreciate you i'm now a
multi-millionaire in property and thanks
for believing when i was a kid
but like i think just sometimes just
giving that value and just kind of
giving people that a bit of love bit of
care a lot of
agents don't do that they're just like
no you don't do that no
and at the back of me i've also got my
mentor that i would run things through
if
things didn't feel like i needed them or
it wasn't quite
of an understanding then i would contact
my mentor
yeah who's he's got the best part of 150
properties
in blackpool and been doing it 30 odd
years if there's not a problem
that she's not been through and if i
can't absorb
her knowledge take it on board and react
to it
yeah it's all right here telling me but
if or or
informing me of a story or or going
through
what mentoring is to um
and then reacting to that then it's like
her pissing in the wind basically i
don't believe anyone is self-made
i think that you you see if you see
people of succeeding in property or
multi-millionaires whatever
they're only there because of people
that have helped them get them there
absolutely
and i'm glad that you credit your mentor
because i mean for me i just credited
michael stone
yeah he's not my mentor and then i've
got all these people on the web have
trained me helped me believed in me
and i think that's you know for me i
think that's vitally important
yeah very very much
hello why
[Music]
i love that last house i'm so grateful
that you took me around
it it's a beautiful property and again
potentially in the future i can it's one
of those properties that i could flip
back for personal use if i needed how
many
how many properties do you own around
here in total i've got uh
actually i have five in total i've got a
cottage in cumbria
uh one on which we've just renovated and
sold
okay hobby rent to die
yeah he loves these he calls them rented
buyers i call them lease option
agreements
mine's the posh way for saying that yeah
you just say exactly what it is
it's red to buy it this is probably
number two we're here yes it is
oh wow
sorry oh my goodness so leave all this
little penthouse
oh my goodness you can see everything
of blackpool you can see what a complete
and utter
lovely place it is well it will it will
be
uncomplete yeah so no no it's not a big
one so listen they're spending 43
billion pounds that's the plan in this
area
so right now this this penthouse or this
whole block
is like really modern looking outside
it's new but then the roads around it
look a bit
i'll put it this way i'm worrying about
my car right now
do i not yeah it's good people right
great i do see my good people but then
but if they're developing the area
that's the thing if you buy in an area
that's already
the whole area is really pristine
there's gonna be no capital appreciation
yeah
whereas if you buy an area where they're
planning to develop it
right now properties in blackboard are
very cheap yes so you're wanting good
cash for angry capitals appreciation
love it show me around okay so outside
um from the management company
well you can actually get on the roof oh
come on this is too much
yeah this is finished here so the part
is for a reason hot tub
hot tub spiral spiral staircase
onto the top and have a complete roof
garden live garden reef clearance oh
dude you're killing me how much did you
pay for this a hundred thousand oh you
didn't
a hundred thousand and what are you
paying on you can literally see the
pepsi max
yeah and on a great day
we can see the sea honestly man i am so
glad that i came i almost didn't come
here i was like let's skip the penthouse
now i'm thinking
i want to stay at the penthouse yeah on
100 grand
what how much you're spending on it to
refurb it i'll probably spend when i
finish i'll probably spend about
well to probably to put these uh gates
in which are obviously a specialised
situation then they need to be secured
in and then
you know so it's a whole lot of but i'm
probably looking about 40 grand how am i
struggling with the work once you're
done
about i'm hoping the best part of 250
quarter of a million but i mean to be
honest with and it's this this play even
if it's not worth a quarter of a million
it will be worth a lot more than that in
a few years to me
uh this is not what this is not up this
isn't for sale
i will never
chris no it isn't so
this is the only one this is the same
chris that i know yeah
this is the same chris the the glenn
i wish i got in first bro i wish i'd so
this is a lease option agreement
i could i could kill this dude right
here
so chris the same dude that i know
from the financial freedom challenge
yeah you've secured this on a
rent to own lease option
three years this one how much cash flow
is this going to make you each month
four three three yeah
uh four three three yeah are you ready
to have room by room
yeah plus five fifty yeah plus five
fifty yeah
another five day oh wow another five
fifty yeah yeah
and then when this one's done yeah
another five fifty okay plus five fifty
2000 just over 2083. by the way
you're not like buying the scarborough
figures
conservative you know blackpool market
better than just about anyone
you manage that's what you do you're a
property manager yeah okay
two thousand you're gonna rent this
place out for what are you paying chris
each month
uh a pair chris 800 okay yeah
yeah and is that just when or was that
partly to buy it
that the whole amount that i pay in is
to come off the price of the property in
three days time
okay so basically you're paying me
nothing so that 2000
is yours because you're you're just
using it
to buy it and then the profit in that
is is obviously going to reduce it down
to a pencil between
albion and here yeah cost me nothing and
what's
the option you have the option to buy in
three years for how much
400 000. oh man honestly i'm feeling
something sick because when did you
agree through chris
uh pre-coverage
about six months ago in fact it will be
six months i was with
chris just over a year ago yeah
what was i thinking what was he thinking
what was he thinking what do you mean
what was he thinking what was he
thinking to give me for a hundred grace
steal well why did he give you 400
rounds uh to be fair he's
looking at retiring he's just once he
just wants to to go in but
he's like you're breaking my heart
though yeah because this deal
the thing is with this deal i'm glad
it's in your hands
yeah but i'd rather in my hands so so
i think you know about the property you
know um what road was it on the one that
is moreland
yes that's normal now that property
i found well glenn found that who's one
of my students
managed it didn't work out yeah i'm
already thinking that you've now bagged
that as well
uh potentially you're managing it i'm
currently managing it yeah
how's that going great absolutely
how is that going great it's full and
taking him it's taking him just shy
of two and a half thousand pounds a
month it's making him two and a half
thousand pounds yeah
but how is that so because i heard that
the house was a complete and utter
disaster
it was uh and what i did was take it on
board
uh turned it around uh exited
um uh glenn from the contract
um i think glenn walked away from it was
like it sucks
by the way glenn is a smart guy he's a
great guy
what happened with that why was it i
think it was a choice of
uh i think it was tenant uh
clientele so he had bad tents yeah is it
full of homes not well managed
okay is it fully talented now yeah fully
tempted do you have the keys
i do can we go look at it of course you
can of course we won't go inside the
rooms we'll go in the communal areas
i want to see this this is you know what
i'm having my world blown apart right
now
come on man let's go look at this house
so when did you first meet chris
uh i was introduced to chris
when we found out glenn had released the
property
and it was going on where he's actually
trying to source a deal
for um for a gentleman over in the
if it wasn't for glenn and that whole
deal would you have met chris
yeah so if it wasn't for glenn you
wouldn't have this penthouse yeah
so we have to thank glenn absolutely
everything happened for a reason i want
to go see this house man
[Music]
here we are not being here in a year
just over a year there you go
oh this is crazy a trip down memory lane
i never thought i'd see this house again
until until literally today yeah yeah so
at this property what we've got we've
got four
four nurses and again quite small
but we've got enough fridge space now um
whereas it wasn't previous to
this right here this was where we signed
the lease option agreement wow yeah
right here
over a year ago now right so anyway so
you've got
you've got four nurses so i've got four
nurses in
uh in the hmr side of the property
and uh in the in the flat below
we've got a long-term uh long-term life
uh that's rented to
a couple that's about to retire and how
do they pay
they pay six fifteen months and when
they retire they're gonna stay here or
yeah the plan is to sell the property
stay here they want to be closer to
family
and pass that on to um pass that on to
um the current residency yeah on to
their children so the whole job
so this whole property how much the
nurse is paying
for each room uh they're paying
for 450 per month per room
per room so that's 450 900
1800 yeah plus 650 650 so that's
2450 yeah and it's all full
and they're good tenants yeah geez
now i know we can't in this property i
know we can't see much of it because
it's all tenanted
is this the only communal space no no no
no
so we've got a lounge so what we've done
is put tvs into the rooms
we've just taken it to that next level
really
because i'm sure that glenn was thinking
about trying to rent this out
as a bedroom or something potentially
this could come as a bedroom but that
was i think was at the point
that was struggling quite a bit and
actually if you keep your standards and
you keep you thinking and keep your
finances there and don't
overcrowd yes legally you can yeah
rendering so so there's no problem there
we're taking that extra money
and some people was but actually if you
keep that quality in there
and somewhere they've got somewhere to
start too because i'm thinking
if the rooms and if it's the same
blackboard but if they're all 100 square
feet
then you don't need a communal area no
and these rooms are all 100 square feet
yes yeah
they're big rooms yeah yeah so putting
four people together
is a bit like putting a team of people
together yeah
so if you if you understand people
better
i think uh in a much deeper sense so
what are their personalities so a little
secret that we
use corporately when i was working for
harvesters
uh was to put teams of people together
was to allocate them
sort of a personality colour that gives
you uh like a bit like a personality
test
yeah it gives you what type of person
they are what they're interested in
a minute later what you do is actually
put the colours of people actually
listen listen
talk to me about this because this is
crazy now are you telling me that if you
have a tenant
you'll literally kind of profile them to
see if they fit with the other tenants
yes
really yeah yeah how can how can you how
can you do that
without discriminating how can you say
you're a little bit of a loud mouth
i don't think you'd fit in very well
with it can you how can you what you'll
do is you'll say come and look at the
property
yeah see what you think of the property
then what you'll do is you'll play
cleveland and say why don't you come
fatigue meet the other tenants
ah okay come on down this is how you're
going to be living
if you're going to be living with
another person it's not it's how people
live with each other yeah and to
understand people so if you're not sure
about someone you'll say to them
hey great you're interested why don't
you come on down
yeah have some tea with the other guys
and then and then we'll take it from
there
yeah and then if they don't come or if
they come and it's really awkward they
won't want to move in
that's genius that's a great nugget and
actually what that does yes
it was longer yes it was a little bit
more costly
do you think the thing is with a lot of
investors and i can relate to this isn't
investing this is the thing like
as an investor you want money right yeah
your money so it's easy
when you've got hmo property to be like
right let's fill the rooms real fast
bang bang bang
bang and because i'm sure that glenn
filled this property the whole thing
within 72 hours
yes so from literally getting the keys
he
filled it with the temperature and at
the time i was like concerned i remember
being like
concerned i said that doesn't sound how
have you vetted them but a lot of people
were saying
that's amazing you filled it real fast
but what you're saying is the opposite
actually
hang in there and just get the right
tenants
paying the right rents and then you're
going to have a much easier ride for the
coming few years that i would never put
on that basis i would never once i
understand their personality
and i've done that personality test on
them without sort of because i'm good
with people that's what i
that's what i was employed to do was put
teams of people together
to to work towards a common goal in
achieving bottom line profit for a
corporate company
that it's nothing what do you think what
do you think of landlords that will just
whack in a student
then put in a professional a nurse then
put someone in benefits
it just does not work it's terrible the
question i would ask to your question
uh of course you've set yourself up for
six thousand what would you rather would
you rather wait a month
and have money consistently for the next
three four years
or do you have money from day one then
there's a month missing because you've
had to refl
but richard that's the golden question
but it's about discipline but this is
this is the same thing i was chatting
with a builder
yesterday and i was saying to the
builder would you rather me give you a
hundred grand now
or would you rather be giving you a
grand a month forever
and he said i'll grind them up forever
but a lot of builders will be like i'll
take your
and a lot of investors i want it fast i
want it and it's that poor mentality
it's the same kind of as lottery winners
it's quick money that lost money no such
thing as a quick fix
no it's just it's about it's about
thinking actually how can i
systemize this now can i set this up for
passive income that's financial freedom
not fast fast quick money tomorrow
financial improvement is systems
and financial freedom you build up to
yeah it doesn't happen overnight
yeah so how did chris feel
when he was happy with the original
setup that myself and glenn agreed with
him
yeah which i think from memory i have to
check but i think he was seven or seven
fifty a month he was dead
it wasn't more than that he was happy
but now
you're managing it for him yeah and he's
making the full
over 2000 pounds a month is he really
happy
is he was he disappointed when when we
pulled the plug on the deal
where's chrissa uh chris is a place
where he's
very happy yeah and i bet he is
yeah he's absolutely over the moon his
property is cared for
um it's got great tenants in and
again once again it's hands-free but the
thing is as well
is why would chris have not in the first
place
just gone oh can you manage my property
what do you think the people
that pass their houses over and rent to
rent the lease options
are those sellers vulnerable uh
dim-witted or wha or what what's
happening there because you've got the
adoption agreement yourself
yeah i've got a lease option agreements
myself um
i don't think it's unethical uh
i think it's great business
and i think some investors or people
selling these lease option agreements
it's the better situation for them
you know what i think i think the real
key to all of this is having good
management in place
i think it is because the reason that
someone would say
have my house just give me 750 a month i
know you'll probably rent it for 3 000
a month i don't care just give me 750 is
because they can't be
bothered with the management with
dealing with
agents with messing around they just
want their guaranteed peace of mind and
if they're at a stage of life
whereby they they don't they don't need
the hassle right
then it makes sense for them yeah
they'll happily i've got properties
where i've passed them on rental rents
to people
i know my i know they're making 500 a
month plus on my houses
guess how i feel i don't care because i
don't have a single phone call to deal
with
so it just depends where you're at on a
season of life
yeah this property didn't work out but
what i find strange
and interesting is this very same
property it's you know what for me it's
almost
kind of almost put me off a little bit
doing like i know you've not even seen
it
but doing a challenge with someone for a
week because it's like
even if we get the property and even if
the property is
a good property it's it's not enough to
just find the property
no it's not you've got to have that
mindset in place
you've got to want to achieve it and if
your heart's not in it
then it's like pissing in the wind into
it you've got to have the motivation to
continue that
yeah it's almost a bit like you know you
know when you see
ongoing and it never ever leaves and
until you've got
you should never be satisfied until that
property is full and
even when it's full it still needs to be
cared for
yeah it is an ongoing thing and it can
be transferred it can be
it can be passive but i don't want
financial freedom i'm running the
business for my clients that want
friends
but for the investor it can be passive
but they've still got to put the time in
to work
and finding that right management
company absolutely you know
and for me as well and listen i'm
friends with glenn
i'm still friends with ben and i think
he's a great guy and he's a good
entrepreneur and he did remarkably well
but i think do you know when you see
kids and they
they may be inherited and glenda didn't
hear this glenn found this property
himself
you know and i helped him and trained
him but he found this and he was well so
i don't want to undermine what glenn did
but you know when like kids maybe
inherit a business
yeah but they don't have all what it
takes to continue managing this and
they'll mess it up
yeah and it's about quite easy so i
probably trained glenn
in that week how to find the property
how to package other deals how to
but probably what i didn't spend enough
time on is how to manage it and
i probably in hindsight should have
spent more time maybe not done it in a
week maybe
in two weeks spent the second week
finding the management companies
and all that that's my lesson to manage
them i think so
successfully i think so and i think what
glenn did was a success this
this probably didn't work out yeah a lot
of his other properties did he's living
now
in a lease option agreement he is do you
know that
uh yeah and and that's through a friend
uh uh
andrea uh that touch took place with him
so he's doing well i was sort of in the
background and
uh she actually informed her that uh he
was he was living he was
moving properties yeah it was moving
home so he's doing well he's a great
great great guy but it's just
interesting to see how the same property
can be bad for one person good for
another person
it shows that it's about the person and
the after skills rather than just the
property itself yes we're not in a
bricks and mortar business with a people
business
yes absolutely i just can't believe how
much of a crazy small world property
investment is
so i worked with glenn glenn found a
deal
many of his deals went well one of his
deals didn't go well because of that
andrea put glenn in touch with lee lee
then was introduced to chris the
landlord
lee then got lots of deals from chris
and he's making good money
i've now been introduced to lee from
andrea my student
lee's kindly showing me around his
houses and different things i'm learning
loads
it's just such a small world be kind to
people because you never know
when you meet someone when they're going
to be your landlord or they're going to
be your investor or they're going to be
your fun
like my goodness lee i love you bro
thank you so much for showing me around
your house
check this dude out check him out he's a
fantastic
man and a great property knowledgeable
management company i'm going to leave
your details in the description what's
it been like spending the last day or so
with me
busy yeah and andrew has now showed up
as well
we know andrea financially free in
property as well
building a portfolio so honestly guys
i'm gonna head back down to london
now but what a whirlwind what an
adventure
guys if you want to be part of the fun
you want to be part of the action
of course the first thing you need to do
is smash the like button then you need
to subscribe
then you need to go and watch a load of
more videos i'm gonna leave andrea's
winners on a wednesday video right here
but just just get in the family get in
the network build your education
absolutely see you next time